today i am going to demonstrate a simple
way to attach drip tape to a header pipe
and to plug the end of the drip tape
the first thing that you will want to do
to attach the lathe flat to the header
pipe is attach the drip tape to the
fitting
twisting the fitting to the right will
tighten it so that it won't come off
when you turn the water on
then take a phillips head screwdriver
and punch a hole in the lay flat header
we are doing this part with the water on
it makes it easier to punch the hole but
you will get wet be careful to use a
screwdriver with a head that is slightly
smaller than the fitting so that it
doesn't leak around the fitting
then push the fitting into the hole you
should be able to hear or feel a pop
when the fitting slides into the hole
with the water on it will flow through
the tape and out the other end if you
haven't plugged it yet
to plug the tape make sure the water is
cut off
cut off a 1 to 2 inch piece from the end
fold the tape over twice then inhale so
that it will easily slip inside the
piece you have cut off
now your drip tape is ready to go to
sure it stays in place turn the water on
and get all the kinks out so the water
is flowing to the end of the drip tape
and you have your place where you want
it
then take a regular garden hose and
place soil every foot or so on top of
the drip tape to weigh it down so that
it won't get displaced by high wind be
careful not to hit the tape with the
hole you'll be able to apply water
directly to the plant without getting
the plant or fruit whip this is a great
way to conserve water reduce plant
disease spread and reduce food safety
risk we hope this video was very useful
please check out our video series to
learn all the steps in installing a
simple irrigation system on a small
phone thank you
you